l'ukraine rappelle donc deux cent mille
réservistes de 18 à 60 ans ils doivent
être mobilisable à tout moment ces
dernières heures les troupes russes ont
envahi les zones séparatistes jusqu'où
iront telle personne le ca par vladimir
poutine bien sûr bonjour gulliver craag
on vous retrouve en direct de kiev
l'ukraine dit se préparer à toutes les
éventualités et s'apprête aussi à
appliquer l'état d'urgence de quoi
s'agit-il
oui c'est le secrétaire du conseil
national de sécurité de défense où
l'occident ni love qui a déclaré
aujourd'hui que le cren appliquerait
l'état d'urgence sur tout son territoire
sauf les régions de donetsk et de
louanges ou at-il dit malheureusement un
état d'urgence est déjà en place dont la
partie de ces régions que l'ukraine
contrôle depuis plusieurs années déjà
c'est nouveau pour le reste de l'ukraine
mais les mesures appliquées monsieur
danilov a expliqué varieront selon la
situation dans telle ou telle région en
fait c'est juste une base juridique cet
état d'urgence pour pouvoir mettre
rapidement en place différentes sortes
de restrictions et de limitation il va y
avoir une garde un dispositif
sécuritaire autour de bâtiments et
d'objectifs stratégiques a augmenté ça
c'est certain dans cet état d'urgence si
non limitation sur les transports
éventuellement couvre-feu des choses
comme ça rien de tout cela n'est
introduit tout de suite d'emblée mais
pourrait être introduite à tout moment
dans certaines villes certaines régions
si elles le gouvernement estime cela
nécessaire
quelles sont les nouvelles de l'est y at
il des mouvements de troupes
alors oui les autorités ukrainiennes
notamment du dans le ministère de
l'intérieur qui publie maintenant
régulièrement des des briefings il y à
des mouvements un peu partout de
véhicules militaires qu'ils décrivent
tout le temps maintenant comme des
véhicules militaires de la fédération de
russie en réalité on ne sait pas quand
il parle de cela si on parle de
véhicules militaires récemment arrivé
est pour ainsi dire officiellement
depuis la russie ou bien ces véhicules
qui étaient déjà là mais sans que la
russie ne l'avouent il était déjà là
depuis plusieurs années mais oui
beaucoup de mouvement est beaucoup
beaucoup de tirs d'artillerie aussi à
peu près le même niveau d'intensité
selon les militaires ukrainien que ces
derniers jours beaucoup de zones civiles
qui sont bombardés j'ai parlé tout à
l'heure à un habitant de chasse tiers
qui m'a dit qu'ils n'avaient ni eau
courante ni gaz ni électricité dans son
immeuble et que l'immeuble voisin
c'était pareil les autorités donnent le
chiffre de
1940 domicile dans l'est de l'ukraine
qui sont actuellement sans électricité à
cause de ces combats l'avenir de la
sécurité européenne se décide en ukraine
dit à l'instant le président zelensky
merci beaucoup d'éleveurs pour ces
éléments l'europe